what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to pop culture explain and
when i was a little kid the olsen twins
mary kate and ashley olsen were
everywhere now some of you guys may not
know who they are so as a brief little
two sentence summary they basically
started out playing michelle tanner on
full house when they were literal
infants but by the mid-1990s they built
an absolute
empire of made for tv movies and looked
poised to take over the world so who
would have guessed that in 2021
they would have both been eclipsed in
popularity by their younger sister
elizabeth star of the upcoming disney
plus series
won division but don't feel bad for mary
kate and ashley olsen despite not acting
in decades their estimated combined net
worth
is like 500 million dollars due in part
to their wildly successful high-end
fashion line but for this video we're
focusing on elizabeth olsen now as we
get into this video
i do have a question for you guys if you
guys had to choose
who you think is better scarlet witch or
captain marvel
who do you think it would be leave your
comment down below i would love to hear
from you guys
but getting into elizabeth olsen she was
born on february 16th in 1989
in sherman oaks california now like her
older sisters elizabeth began acting at
a very early age and her first
credited role on imdb was listed as how
the west was fun
a 1994 made for tv movie starring the
olsen twins where elizabeth then simply
going by lizzy played out the pivotal
role of
girl in card now she would appear in a
few more of her sister's projects
throughout her childhood but nothing
really consequential outside of playing
girl with flowers in an episode of full
house and so in 2004
mary kate's eating disorder became
public which attracted a lot of negative
media attention and which according to
an interview she did with nylon magazine
almost caused elizabeth to give up
acting because she felt that it wasn't
worth the hassle of dealing with what
she described as
abusive behavior from the press which is
true the media after all
did get diana princess of wales killed
in england now after graduating high
school
elizabeth attended the tisch school of
arts at new york university and also
spent a semester studying theater in
moscow before graduating in 2013.
but olsen's breakout role came in 2011
as she starred
in martha marcy mae marlene that's not a
difficult name at all but it was the
tongue twister of a film about a woman
who experienced psychological trauma
brought about by her time in a cult and
so the film debuted at the 2011 sundance
film festival and its director shawn
durkin won the festival's u.s
directing award for best drama now the
film was also shown at the prestigious
keynes film festival that year and
despite not making much money it was a
critical success
and olson was praised for her
performance in the lead role noted film
critic roger ebert even called olsen
a genuine discovery which i don't really
know what that means what's the opposite
of a genuine discovery
like you already knew they were good and
you're just now telling people i don't
really know but from his perspective
she had the ability to convey a wide
range of emotions that were first
starring role earned olson
several awards such as most promising
performer at the chicago film critics
association awards best breakthrough
performance from the alliance of women
film journalists and best actress at the
vancouver film critic circle awards
among others
interestingly enough another of olsen's
films premiered at the sundance film
festival that year a horror film called
silent house in which olsen played the
lead role now the film would see a
theatrical release in the united states
on march 9th in 2012 and would net 13
million dollars at the box office so
nothing crazy and while silent house was
not nearly as well received by critics
as martha marcy may marlene it did earn
olsen the best leading actress award at
the 2013
fangoria chainsaw awards so i'm sure
that was a big deal for her but from
there olson continued to take roles in
movies and in 2013
was nominated for the bafta rising star
award which as you can probably guess
from its name
is given to an emerging actor or actress
and has been won by such actors as james
mcavoy kristen stewart
shyla buff and tom holland now olsen
didn't win juno temple did which
i'm going to go ahead and say was
probably not the right call given the
fact that i've never heard of juno
temple but anyway i'm sure it's an honor
to just be nominated but in 2013
olson appeared in a few more films the
most notable of which were kill your
darlings a film about influential
writers from the beat generation
an old boy an action film directed by
spike lee and also starring josh brolin
and samuel l
jackson but 2014 would prove to be a
huge year for olsen as she would appear
in two blockbuster films the first
she barely appeared in but it would be
the first time olson would portray the
character that she's most famous for and
the
credits scene of captain america the
winter soldier olson makes her first
appearance in the marvel cinematic
universe portraying wanda maximov who is
known to comic book fans
as the scarlet witch although up to this
point she's never actually
ever been referred to as the scarlet
witch in the movies she's only seen on
screen
for like 10 to 15 seconds and then
doesn't really speak or even get
referred to
by name we simply just see her moving
some objects using her mind but it sets
the stage for olsen's most iconic role
that same year olson would have what was
really her first
major role in a blockbuster picture as
she starred in godzilla which premiered
on march 16 2014
and really revitalized a franchise that
had been super popular at one time but
it honestly been pretty irrelevant for a
while but the 2014 reboot was received
pretty well by both critics and fans it
made 529 million dollars at the box
office which was enough that warner
brothers decided to release a sequel to
the film in 2019 but 2015 was another
big year for olsen
she starred alongside tom hiddleston and
i saw the light a biopic about country
singer hank williams senior for which
she won the hollywood rising star award
from the duville american film festival
but the big development of 2015
was of course the proper introduction of
wanda maximov into the mcu and avengers
age of ultron throughout
the course of the movie spoiler alert
for a movie that i know you've probably
seen a million times wanda goes from
villain
to hero and by the end of the movie we
see wanda at the avengers headquarters
ready to be trained to become a member
of the team now this development is
somewhat important because it meant that
olsen would be a part of the marvel
cinematic universe for years to come
and in fact she subsequently appeared in
three additional mcu films captain
america civil war avengers infinity war
and avengers in-game now since becoming
a mainstay of the mcu olsen has appeared
in three of the 10
highest grossing films of all time
including the highest grossing film ever
avengers in-game which grossed nearly
2.5
billion dollars worldwide now in
addition to starring in the biggest
films
ever 2019 was a big year for olson
personally as she announced her
engagement to her boyfriend of three
years
robbie arnett a musician that's
currently a member of the band mio green
but avengers end game brought about the
end of phase 3 of the marvel cinematic
universe and was widely seen as the
finale that every mcu movie had been
leading up to
leaving fans to wonder what was next and
so in november of 2019
disney launched his own streaming
service disney plus which was not only
going to be home to the already released
mcu films but also to some all-new
series
set in the mcu continuity it was
announced that one of those shows would
feature olson's character
wanda maximov and her love interest in
the mcu films the vision played by paul
bettany who'd basically died in avengers
in-game
twice actually spoiler alert again i
guess but the concept of wand division
according to kevin feige the architect
of the mcu will be to see what wanda is
actually capable of and will finally
introduce the name
scarlet witch to the mcu but filming for
wand division began in november of 2019
and it entered a temporary hiatus on
march 1 2020. the hiatus was only
supposed to last four weeks but it was
stalled by the covet 19 pandemic and so
filming once again started in september
now production for the series was
finished in november and one division is
slated to premiere on disney plus on
january 15
2021 and so immediately after finishing
her work for one division olson began
filming her next film set in the mcu
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness which is slated for a release in
march of 2022
and will most likely clear up the
multiversal effects of what scarlet
witch has done
during the events of wand division which
will most likely just be house of
m but that's basically the career of
elizabeth olsen up to this point but as
long as people keep watching the marvel
movies which i don't really see a reason
why they wouldn't i'd say she has a role
as wanda maximoff for as long as she
wants and even though she's already
appeared in the highest grossing film of
all time which is kind of a tall order
to duplicate because of her commercial
success in the role as well as the
reputation she's earned as a wildly
talented actress i would imagine
that what we've discussed here is just
the beginning of a very long career in
film but that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to pop culture explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you